Another useful case for
Promises is when you need some
sort of flow control. This is an
example where you would probably
find out on a back end and maybe
something like Node.js, when you
are creating a database. We
have like a PostId that someone
is going to give us like one,
two, or three, and each of those
is associated with post by
myself, Chris Coyier, Addy
Osmani. Then there is also
another table that contains the
authors. It tells you who the authors'
name is. If you want more
information about the author,
like their twitter and their bio,
then we have to go to a separate
table. Just imagine that these
two are raised here, these are
like a database. We are going to
sort of to simulate ourselves
connecting to a database, which
won't be accessible immediately,
which is why we are going to
need to use these Promises.
What we're going to do is we're
going to create two separate
functions that both going to
return Promises, and then we are
going to chain them together.
The first one is going to be a
function called GetPostByID.
What that will do is going to...
It's going to be called
GetPostByID, and we're going to
pass it something like 2. It's
going to look up in our database
here for a post that has an ID
of 2. We're going here. First
thing we need is a Promise,
because we cannot access it from
our database immediately. It has
to do a round trip around back
and forth to the database. So we
are going to return new Promise,
that gives us a 'resolve' and a
'reject'. Now we need to go
inside of here and find the post...
So when the PostID...
We are gonna loop over every
single one of these, and when
the ID is matched up to the one
that get passed into this
function, so when it is 2, we're
going to find the Post there,
and we're going to say if there
is a Post, then Resolve and give
the Promise to Post, otherwise
we are going to Reject, say,
'Error no post was found'. In
order to simulate this, so it
takes time, what we can do is as
you can see SetTimeOut, just
wrap this in a SetTimeOut, which
will sort of simulate the taking
200 ms round trip. If you like
to run it instantly, you don't
have to do this part, but it's
totally up to you. OK, so what
do we here? Let's have a couple
comments here. Create a new
promise. We are using a
SetTimeOut to mimick a database.
We find the POST we want. If
there is a POST that is self-
explanatory, 'resolve'. So 'send
post' back, otherwise we 'reject'
, and we don't have an error
there, that's self-explanatory.
That is our GetPostByID. So we
should be able to say
GetPostByID, then it should give
us a Post. Just cancel 'log to post'
. So let's see. The browser..
There we go. There is a 'post'
immediately. We got PostByID(2).
It shows us there's Chris Coyier.
So if I'm going to change this
to two seconds, in order it
doesn't show us immediately, and
we see it after two seconds.
I'll keep it to 200 ms, nice and
fast. We want to do this thing
that I like to call 'hydrating',
where the author of this Post is
just a string of 'Wes Boss', but
I want to replace it with the
the Author object for a 'Wes Bos'
that has my name as well as my
twitter, as well as my bio. I'm
going to create a new function
called hydrateAuthor, which is
going to take in the Post. Why
we are going to do this is
because once the Post comes back
in this first one right here, we
are going to 'cancel log' it,
but we are also going to call
another hydrateAuthor and pass
it the Post. This hydrateAuthor
function is going to return a
Promise itself. So if we return
a Promise inside of the Then,
it's going to allow us to chain '
.then' on to the next line.
Let's write the actual function
first. Return new Promise
and inside of here we
gonna say const authorDetails =
authors.find(), and we're going
to say person, and we're going
to find the one, where person.
name = post.name. So the post
that gets past in is going to be
a post that was found in the
previous function. We are going
to filter through all of these
authors, until we find an author
name that aligns exactly with
the author name of the post that
was written. So we should have
authorDetails here, and we can
say if there's authorDetails
resolve, and pass not just
authorDetails, because we want
to hydrate the author. We're
going to say post.author =
authorDetails. We gonna
override this string of 'Wes Bos'
with an object of all the
details about me. Then we
resolve the entire post once
again, otherwise, we will reject
and not find the author. Good.
Let's step through that once
more. We create a function that
takes in the Post; we create a
new Promise; we find the Author;
and if there is an Author, then
we hydrate the Post object with
the Author object, otherwise we
reject it. So we should be able
to now say '.then' on here, 'post'
, 'post the log the post'.
Because this hydrateAuthor
returns a Promise, and we return
that Promise to the 'then', we
can then unchain 'then' unto the
end of that. Finally, we should
catch the error. If there is an
error thrown in anytime, we
should be able to cancel that
error. We'll see when we refresh
here. We got a bit of a problem
here. We cannot find the author,
which is good thing we are
catching here. So what is the
problem that we have? We got a
problem going on... We can just
debug through here. Debugger
statement in 'go hydrateAuthor'.
Our closure has a Post object
which is the author is 'Chris Coyier'
. person.name equals... Oh, post.
name is not 'post.name', it's
'post.author'. It's the 'post.author'
is 'Wes Bos'. Debugger takes
this out. Back to our console
here. Here we go. We should see..
This is the first console log
from our first one, which
happens right here. We can take
this out. The second object
that gets logged here is
hydrateAuthor version. You can
see the Author is now hydrated
with bio, name and twitter, as
well as ID and title of the
actual post. So I did this by
passing 2. I can pass 1 I should
be able to get something like
this. Shows me the 1 from me,
but if I pass something like 5,
which doesn't exist, hopefully
our catch will catch it. Here
we go - no post was found.
Similarily, if we also go for a
post 3 here, but we
accidently spelled his name
wrong. It's not going to be able
to find that author. So we
should say 'Post was found, but
no author was found'. Here we go -
'Cannot find the author'. It's
the nice example of when you're
chaining, because this is a
little bit complex, there's a
lot going on in here. What you
can do is you can sort of sweep
all this complexity into a nice
little function, where you know
how that works, you can test how
that works. Then you can chain
them together, whenever it is
you that actually need them. And
bring this back, there's money,
make sure we're working, and
we're good to go.